jamie lynn spears this is your story
what did it feel like to be able to
finally get your story out because one
thing that's evident in reading the book
is that you had to stay quiet about a
lot of things for a long time quite
honestly like
scary and uncomfortable but also really
healing and
and um
and
it makes me feel
strong yeah but also vulnerable so it's
weird to feel all those things at once
but at the end of the day the truth is
the truth and
and saying it out loud makes it
makes it um
makes it real i guess you talk so much
about your family keeping up appearances
and uh wanting to put on a front for the
world and you're all in the spotlight so
with this book what did you want to
clear up the most i think to an extent
every family has a certain degree of
wanting to appear a certain world where
whether it's in a small town or a big
city you know you all want to
kind of to an extent keep things private
or keep up appearances and
and so i think that it was just
becoming so personal and to where i was
taking that as to where my own life and
my own personality i had to be perfect
all the time and that's a pressure no
one should feel much less when you're
still a young girl and i just think that
it was important for me to really speak
about this openly and honestly so that
my daughters could hear from my
perspective about all the flaws and all
the messiness i never want them to feel
the pressure to be perfect the mistakes
that i make or they make being open and
honest about that is probably healing
for them but also other people freeing
yes yeah and you talk a lot about your
parents you know you guys are a very
close family about the trauma that you
dealt with from your father's drinking
from your mom's thing you call
pretending what do you wish they'd done
differently sitting here as an adult and
as a parent now for you and your
siblings you know that's hard to say
especially because i am a parent i'm
sure there's things that my children
will tell me i did wrong in the future
but obviously i wish my dad never would
have drank but again he is a human and
he has mistakes whole family does and i
think that i have to not think so much
about what i would change and more so
about how i can change my life going
forward and what i can take from it as
well as using my pain or using my
experiences to hopefully help others and
i think that's really the only thing i
can focus on because you can would have
coulda should have your whole life
i'm only responsible for me and my
actions moving forward i can't worry
about
what anything happened in the past where
do you and your siblings stand with mom
and dad today it's a healing process
that i know that i'm working through i
can't speak for anyone else because
each of us are in this family and we all
are dealing with things individually and
from our own
point of view so i think we have to
respect each other's process as we go
through it but it's in real time i mean
i don't have all the answers i'm just
trying to do the best i can every day
with everything that is you know going
on just like many other families in this
world well you talk about dealing with
the onslaught that you get from fans
from the media what is the biggest
misconception
you maybe wanted to clear up with this
book for yourself this book isn't about
me trying to clear up anything it's
about me using my voice and showing my
daughters that your voice is important
that's what this book is about
but i would hope that i guess in the
recent climate that is going on that
people would understand that this is a
situation that's affected many people
and this is my reality that i've grown
up in it's the only reality i know and
i'm allowed to speak about that and i
think it's important to have compassion
for what we don't understand and also
make room for each and every voice
because everyone has their own
experiences and they should all be
respected and heard because we need to
teach everyone that every voice matters
and give them a safe space to share it
you are a spears too you dealt with the
same parents that your sister dealt with
and there's been a lot of discussion
about your sister and your parents and
their relationship but you grew up in
that upbringing as well when you were
writing the book how much did you
grapple with how much you wanted to talk
about your sister because
you're tied forever as you should be as
siblings but at the same time you're
tied forever and that's a catch-22 i
think when you grow up your whole life
really with the motto of you know
protecting others and that became i
wanted to protect everyone else first
besides myself i think it's important
that i was truly open and honest and
used my voice and like you said i grew
up we do have the same parents and that
very much makes us sisters and i love
and support my sister and i respect her
healing process and however she has to
work through things
and all i ask is that i you know have
that same space you get into some
specifics of your childhood of growing
up in hollywood living with your sister
sometimes and your mom sometimes and
there's a couple incidents that you
reveal that are very powerful you talk
at one point about brittany being
paranoid and
getting a knife and bringing you into a
room with her how scary were those times
for you how were you processing that and
what do you think was happening i think
there was a lot of
things that happened in my childhood
that were
very
scary and unsafe and i just think that
it's important that i was able to share
how i felt in those moments
no matter who else is involved in them
you're in the limelight and a lot of
people have come for you
what do you wish those people understood
about you and what do you hope they
maybe get from the book hopefully
understanding that you know i came into
this family 10 years after the last
child that was born and i didn't decide
or make any of these choices i just
learned how to
adapt adapt and i am so thankful for a
lot of the things that i have
experienced whether it was with my
family or
through the environment that we're in
and i think that people just you know
need to understand that i've only ever
tried to be my own person and create a
life in a future for me and my children
that is my own so that i can have this
book to look back on and say yeah it's
scary but that was my voice and that was
my truth and i'm allowed to have that
even if it's messy even if it might hurt
some people's feelings or it might be
scary for myself but i just have to do
what is my truth and my voice were there
times in the last year when you wanted
to speak up and you felt like you
couldn't and you had to you know push
that voice down well i think that what
maybe people forget is like
this is real this is like a real these
are people i really love and care about
i'm processing and working through it
and i don't maybe do that in a public
way but it truly affects me i'm dealing
with these things in a way in real time
that i'm trying to work through and
sometimes that's not always something
you share with the rest of the world as
you go through that were there times
when you wanted to just like oh my gosh
of course here's everything okay here's
how i feel get in the comments with
somebody who's been mean to you of
course you want to but i think that at
the same time like what is that really
going to benefit um i need to focus on
me and my family and my healing process
and i think that
getting into
a conversation with someone who knows
absolutely nothing factual or truthful
is just it's a waste of time for them
and for myself you make it very clear in
the book you're adamant you have not
been involved in your sister's
conservatorship even when she asked you
to get involved with her legally you
said that was not a good place for you
to be with everything that happened in
the past year what did you hope the
outcome would be from your perspective
this is your family what did you want i
wanted for everyone to
be happy and i think that everyone has
that right at the end of the day so i
think that ending the conservatorship is
what my sister wanted so that's what
happened and i support that i never had
any involvement with it i just simply
wanted to be a good sister and i really
since since i was a very little girl
i've just wanted my family to be a
family and um
i want what's best for everyone and so i
think that
that's all i can ever ask for in this
family that is mine do you think people
don't know what you didn't know like i
got a sense reading the book that you
are not privy to a lot of information
about everything i think you have to
remember when this conservatorship came
into place i was a 17 year old about to
have a baby so i think i was pretty
occupied and also i was still a young
girl i didn't understand a lot of the
things there's still a lot of things i
don't understand and perhaps that is you
know something i could have educated
myself more on but i have two children
i'm caring for and when this came into
conception i was a teen mom all alone
trying to figure it out so i just think
that people have to understand that i've
very much
always done what i believe is the right
thing to do in each situation but i can
only do so much with the information
that i have and also
i do have my own life that i am dealing
with things sometimes that i have to put
first but at the end of the day
i've always done
what was the right thing in each moment
with
whatever i've known well the
conservatorship's over have you talked
to brittany where are you guys at she's
engaged she said she's gonna get married
now will you be at the wedding i love
and i support my sister in each and
every way and i'll continue to do that i
just think we're all in a process of
healing this has been a very
up and down year for everyone so i just
think that right now that's you know
that's where we're
focusing on that has your family read
the book they've read like big chunks of
it but i haven't they haven't read it
from first page to last page so i'm
excited for them to read it but i'm also
like i know that obviously i'm going to
say something that's going to make
somebody mad but at the end of the day
this is the truth this is my story and i
think they're more supportive of me
healing
than they are of their feelings getting
hurt one thing that stuck out to me was
when you said that maddie
saved you looking back she does numerous
times in my life but i think the main
thing is that from a very young age i
was again born into a family and a
industry
where a lot of decisions were made for
me my narrative was controlled by other
people i was not allowed to use my voice
unless it was something that made sense
for the overall narrative of the greater
good
and
for the first time when i was pregnant
with matt it was the first time i stood
up for myself and said what i wanted and
that's the first time i heard my voice
and i used it it's striking how when
you're pregnant your parents separated
you and reading the book there's several
times when you can see they kind of
separated you from brittany or britney
from you and your siblings how painful
was that i mean how do you wish that
that hadn't happened because it seemed
like you needed each other at different
points that time was just such a chaotic
time there was a lot of things going on
which i was a young girl who again i
didn't understand much of it so if
people are gonna go out and get the book
what would you tell them they're gonna
get out of it why would you want them to
read this story the overall reason you
know i wrote this book was so that i
could show my daughters to use their
voice and i hope that that tells other
people to do the same even if you're
afraid and even if you feel like it's
something that's scary for you to do
your voice matters you should always
feel like you can control your narrative
and i want to make sure
that i do that and i hope that other
people just do the same and also have
understanding for each other's stories
we don't know everyone's full story or
what they've been through what they're
going through if we can create a safer
space for other people to share what
their voice is then i think that maybe
we'll have a lot more healing in this
world and a lot less judgment
[Music]